much of the generally accepted knowledge
about Watchmen and its making would
likely be loudly shouted down by the
books creators Alan Moore and Dave
Gibbons the inspirations for Watchmen
its creators intentions and the
contributions each brought to the table
are often misunderstood or overlooked
it's a strange irony that in a medium as
concerned with images as comic books the
writers tend to get most of the
attention Watchmen is no exception as
the comics artist Dave Gibbons said when
he spoke to Wired in 2008 people
unacquainted with graphic novels
including journalists tend to think of
Watchmen as a book by Alan Moore that
happens to have some illustrations and
that does a disservice to the entire
form while being interviewed by Neil
Gaiman in 1987 Gibbons said it was his
idea for the cover of Watchmen number
one to be of the now iconic
blood-smeared smiley face it was Gibbons
with Moore's input who designed the
physical appearance of the characters
and perhaps most significantly it was
Gibbons who brought life to watchman's
world Watchmen was one of a number of
superhero comic book series published in
the mid 80s that are often associated
with one another because they're said to
explore the notion of superheroes as
fascist figures
examples include Batman The Dark Knight
Returns and Marvel's squadron supreme in
which superheroes with good intentions
nevertheless turned the u.s. into a
totalitarian state with brutal scenes
and Watchmen of the comedian and dr.
Manhattan killing Vietnamese soldiers
and civilians Rorschach torturing
victims for information or the Minutemen
using their abilities and technology to
break up protests it's easy to see why
readers make the association with
fascism but in a 1987 interview Alan
Moore said his Watchmen characters
weren't fascists Rorschach's not a
fascist he's a nutcase
the comedian's not a fascist he's a
psychopath dr. Manhattan's not a fascist
he's a space cadet they're not fascists
they're not in control of their world
arguably Moore's stated intentions were
much more damning towards superheroes
than any series before or set
more said that he and Gibbons weren't
trying to reveal a fascist meaning in
superheroes our intention was to show
how superheroes could deform the world
just by being there not that they'd have
to take it over just their presence
there would make the difference when
talking about what is unique about
Watchmen the darker subject matter and
the violence are the focus for most
what's too often forgotten though the
visual innovations it brought to comic
books take the covers which were devoid
of fight scenes or heroes posing they
included a Rorschach drawing a torn
black-and-white photo and a spinning
perfume bottle each cover was part of
the first panel of each issue in the
1987 interview Dave Gibbons said the
cover of The Watchmen is in the real
world and looks quite real but it's
starting to turn into a comic book a
portal to another dimension a perfect
example was its fifth issue titled
fearful symmetry each page and panel of
Watchmen number five was designed to act
as a mirror to its opposite likewise the
scenes of each page mirror their
opposites it isn't a secret that the
psychotic Rorschach was based on the
former Charlton comics hero known as the
question but what you may not know is
that Rorschach and his predecessor had a
chance to meet one another kind of in
the question number 17 Vic's age aka the
question finds himself leaning toward
more brutal tactics lamenting the
opportunities he's given his enemies
because he supposedly hasn't dealt with
him harshly enough while in pursuit of a
fugitive
saij takes a plane to Seattle and picks
up a copy of Watchmen at the terminal
newsstand to read on the flight he
doesn't like Rorschach's bigotry but
he's impressed with the skills and
violence he falls asleep on the flight
and dreams of the death of a private eye
he knew except in the dream sage is
Rorschach instead of the question when
he lands and starts working on his case
he finds himself asking what would were
Shaq do when a crook takes him out with
a gun butt to the head
sage utters Rorschach's signature tongue
toward the end of the comic he regrets
trying to emulate the more ultra violent
hero when he's cornered by the crooks
and ask if he has any last words sage
responds yeah Rorschach's sucks
HBO's Watchmen debut to rave reviews and
pretty quickly a couple of things became
clear about the show first the events of
the series take place decades after the
events of the original story second and
more importantly HBO's Watchmen is a
continuation of the comic book story
rather than the movie a brief memorable
scene in the first episode confirms it
as Angela a bar drives her son home from
school the city of Tulsa is pelted with
a heavy torrent of tiny squid-like
creatures
[Applause]
[Music]
in the watchmen graphic novel we learn
Adrian Veidt aka Ozymandias is behind a
conspiracy to violently bring about a
utopia Veidt recruits the world's best
scientists to create a fake alien
behemoth that he then transports to New
York City the hope being that the
world's powers will stop fighting each
other and unite to face this new threat
in the 2009 film this was changed so
that Veidt manufactures an attack that
appears to be from dr. Manhattan with
the same results since we know the alien
squid isn't in the film HBO's Watchmen
can only be a continuation of the
graphic novel it could be these squid
storms will be what uncovers veidt's
conspiracy and we're already seeing
hints of that in watchman's second
episode a news vendor is spouting
conspiracies to a man delivering
newspapers one of the things Watchmen is
known for is its alternate history in
the graphic novel Richard Nixon is
serving his fifth term as president and
the civil rights battles won in the 60s
and 70s never happened because the
superheroes were there to stop the
protests so in the first episode of
Watchmen opens with a 1921 race massacre
on the streets of Tulsa you might think
this is more fictional world building
but it isn't the Tulsa traced Massacre
happened in the real world and if
anything Watchmen only shows the tip of
the iceberg the 1921 Tulsa massacre has
been largely lost from our history books
because of systematic attempts to
cover-up the events the Los Angeles
Times reported in the aftermath of the
killings attempts were made to cover up
the events stories were removed from
newspaper archives and some official
accounts were destroyed this is likely
part of the reason why the official
death count of the massacre is 36 but
more recent estimates put the number
closer to 300 killed along with around
800 injuries according to The Times
story the massacre began after news
circulated that a black man had
assaulted a white woman in an elevator
though later reports suggested he may
have tripped and fallen onto the one
accident the white rioters supported by
the Ku Klux Klan not only killed and
injured black citizens but they
destroyed the black owned businesses of
Tulsa places so successful that Booker T
Washington had coined the community as
quote the black Wall Street of America
if you're familiar with the graphic
novel the movie or both then one of the
biggest differences you'll notice right
away is that in HBO's Watchmen the
masked men and women are working with
the cops in the original story the Keene
Act makes masks vigilantes illegal
except for those working for the
government Congress is pushing through
some new bills can outlaw masks today's
our numbers the only heroes we see
employed by the feds are the comedian
dr. Manhattan and Silk Spectre the rest
of the heroes are either officially
retired or like Rorschach renegades who
the police would love to get their hands
on
so it's something of a shock when with
the exception of the Rorschach inspired
cavalry all of the masked people of
HBO's Watchmen are police it seems
likely this is a result of the white
knight an event that took place some
years before the events of the series
where the cavalry broke into the homes
of most of the Tulsa PD and killed the
officers and their families as they
slept most of the survivors immediately
resign though Angela and chief Jud
Crawford refused to back down so
presumably part of the reason for the
masks is to protect the officers and
their families but certain officers
apparently get special designation and
rise above the yellow mask to
rank-and-file
there's Angela aka sister Knight
lookingglass the Red Scare pirate Jenny
and Panda at least one character from
HBO's Watchmen also appeared in the
graphic novel Adrian Veidt aka
Ozymandias in the first episode
Veidt enjoys himself on a vast Dilek
castle property that he appears to share
with two beloved servants they serve him
a cake with a single candle gift him
with an old pocket watch he tells them
he's written to play he wants the pair
to star in called the watchmakers son
this is a little strange already because
you'd think in his waning years the man
who believes he saved the
world would want to write about himself
but if you know Watchmen then you know
the watchmakers son can only be dr.
Manhattan things get a lot weirder in
the second episode we learn who we
thought were veidt's only servants are
part of a series of identical clones
Veidt watches a rehearsal of his play
which climaxes with the accident that
turns Jon Osterman into dr. Manhattan
including pyrotechnics that kill the
actor playing no one seems particularly
upset with this and Vike directs his
clones to put the dead actor in the
basement with the others what's not as
dramatic but still noteworthy is that
his servants bring him another cake but
this time with two candles assuming
these events happened concurrent to
what's going on in Tulsa
we know a year hasn't passed which
suggests the cake isn't a birthday cake
after all it's something else
the image of the watch recurs over and
over again in the watchmen graphic novel
each chapter ends with a ticking clock
the fourth chapter watchmaker goes back
and forth in time through the lens of
dr. Manhattan's nonlinear point of view
the symbol on dr. Manhattan's forehead
looks something like a watch face though
it's meant to be an atom as does the
blood-splattered smiley face that's
become so iconic and reference to watch
HBO's Watchmen continues this tradition
in images and sounds there's of course
the foreboding tick-tock chant of the
Rorschach inspired seven cavalry
when the Tulsa PD raids a cavalry
safehouse we learned the group is using
old lithium batteries from watches to
build some kind of weapon and there's
the pocket watch adrian veidt's servants
give to him as a present along with the
name of his play the watchmakers son
what does it all mean on one hand just
as in the graphic novel the watches
service countdown to something
cataclysmic this is also likely the
reason why the candles on veidt's cakes
increased by one each episode on the
other hand watchman has always been very
concerned with time and how we perceive
it so the watches are a constant
reminder of our strange relationship
with time HBO's Watchmen hasn't
forgotten its roots and the evidence is
everywhere there are plenty of callbacks
to the graphic novel including
technological advances clearly inspired
by the heroes of the source material in
the first episode after some of the
cavalry members try to escape with their
homemade bomb in a small plane Judd and
pirate Jenny follow in what appears to
be the al ship from the comic in the
second episode we see someone in a wing
to get up inspired by the Watchmen hero
Mothman he falls out of the sky while
the police are investigating crime scene
with Judd was hanged and the Red Scare
beats the winged interloper first
trouble apparently in the world of
Watchmen Mothman technology is their
version of drones there's also a
historical show about the Minutemen
called American hero by the second
episode we get an entire bloody brutal
scene involving hooded justice and group
of robbers the hero was only seen in
flashbacks in the Watchmen graphic novel
and he's a perfect addition here
considering his hood the new symmetry
Judds death and his seeming secret KKK
past there's something disturbingly
poignant about hooded justice in this
narrative check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]